Nos dicen: "Cierto puesto de tacos vende
t tacos por día con una ganancia neta
de 300 dólares. Hacer cada taco cuesta c
dólares y se vende a p dólares. Escribe
una ecuación que relacione t, c y p."
Pausa el video e intenta resolverlo.
Bien, trabajemos juntos. Primero recordemos
lo que sucede en este problema. Sabemos que el
número de tacos vendidos en un día es t, vamos
a escribirlo: t = # de tacos vendidos por día
-al número de tacos vendidos por día-; además,
nos dicen que la ganancia neta es de 300 dólares,
vamos a escribirlo: 300 dólares = la ganancia
neta -300 dólares es la ganancia neta-;
además nos dicen que hacer cada taco cuesta c
dólares, entonces c es el costo por taco,
c = al costo por taco, y por último cada taco se
vende por p dólares, entonces p = al precio por
taco -p es el precio por taco-. Entonces, ¿cómo
podemos encontrar una expresión para la ganancia
neta? Bueno, podemos escribirlo de esta forma:
la ganancia neta = la cantidad total de dinero
que entra - la cantidad total de dinero que se
gasta. ¿Cuál es la cantidad de dinero total que
entra? Bueno, será la cantidad de tacos que se
venden por el precio del taco, entonces será t por p.
Esto será la cantidad de dinero total que entra,
pero obviamente tendremos que restar nuestro costo
total. ¿Cuál será el costo total? Bueno, será
el número de tacos por el costo por taco, esto
será el dinero total que gastamos: t por c, el número
de tacos por el costo por taco. Ahora, observa:
ya hemos escrito todo con variables -bueno, claro,
no hemos escrito la ganancia neta, pero nos dicen
que la ganancia neta es de 300 dólares-, por
lo tanto, si usamos los mismos colores podemos
escribirlo así: 300 = tp - tc. Ahora, es posible
que no nos den la ganancia neta como 300 dólares
por día y en cambio nos dijeran que esta ganancia
neta es una de las variables, y nos dieran una de
las otras variables. Esto también estaría bien, ya
que podríamos usar la misma lógica; lo que sea que
no nos den, podemos definirlo como una variable y
lo que sí nos den -tal vez, no sé, el precio por
taco- lo usaremos como un número dado. Ahora,
sé lo que algunos de ustedes están pensando,
no obtuvieron exactamente esto ya que lo pensaron
de otra forma, tal vez pensaron que la ganancia es
igual al número de tacos por la ganancia por taco,
y ¿cuál es la ganancia por taco? Bueno, será el
precio de cada taco, menos la cantidad de dinero
que cuesta hacer cada taco, y esto también es
completamente cierto. Podemos observar que estas
dos expresiones son algebraicamente equivalentes:
si factorizamos t en la expresión de la
izquierda, obtendremos la expresión de la derecha.